[music playing]
NARRATOR: 1964 was a seminal
year for change in America.
A new generation was
questioning authority
and shaking up the status quo.
1964 was also a pivotal
year in the auto industry,
especially as the
spirit of non-conformity
inspired a brash
engineer at Pontiac.
TAMARA WARREN: John DeLorean
is one of those iconic names
in the auto industry.
He'll always be known
for the DeLorean DMC,
but his legacy
goes farther back.
ANNOUNCER: General Manager
Mr. John Z. DeLorean.
[applause]
NARRATOR: In 1964,
John DeLorean,
along with fellow Pontiac
speed junkie Jim Wangers,
embraced the rebellious
spirit of the day.
They hatched a plan
to make a powerful car
out of their mid-sized Tempest.
John DeLorean had
this great idea.
Because he couldn't put the
big engine in a small car,
he made the big engine an
option, like a box you could
check, a trim package;
like AC or a radio,
or something like that.
Oh, no big deal.
It just has this
rules-flouting big V8 in it.
NARRATOR: DeLorean and Wangers
even gave this new option
package a bold name.
Let me introduce
you to another brand
new series, the GTO.
STEVE LINDEN: GTO
is a great name.
It means Gran Turismo
Omologato, which
means it's a grand touring
car, but they had homologation
rules, which was really just
a fancy way of saying you had
to produce a certain number
and sell it to the public
if you wanted to race it.
Ferrari had a beautiful
car called a GTO,
and I think they
probably just piggybacked
off that name a little bit.
[music playing]
(SINGING) Pontiac,
it's a breakaway car--
breakaway car.
[inaudible]
GREG WALLACE: It's one of
those cars, when you get it out
on the floor and
you walk around it,
it's a home run
from every angle.
From the simulated hood scoops,
and then that great engine
with the chrome valve covers
and the three carburetors on it.
Interior bucket seats were
a big deal at the time,
and a four-speed shifter.
I mean, there's-- nothing
says muscle car like that.
NARRATOR: In addition, marketing
genius Jim Wangers came up
with a brilliant ad campaign.
NARRATOR 2: A guy goes out
and gets a genuine tiger--
a Pontiac GTO, that is--
and guess who
suddenly loves cats?
The advertising campaigns
of the day with the tiger--
the hood would open up, and a
tiger would jump out of the--
I mean, this was all marketing
things that were eye-catching,
you know?
And once people really
see that as a premium
performance vehicle, it
sold itself after that.
NARRATOR 2: The
tiger scores again.
NARRATOR: Priced at only
$2,800, about $22,00 today,
the GTO was a smash hit.
It sold more than 32,000 units
in its first year, the highest
for any first-year Pontiac.
Thanks DeLorean and
his trouble-makers,
Detroit finally saw the demand
for smaller, stylish cars
with big, powerful engines.
The automakers were now
poised to revolutionize
the car industry by taking the
hot rod culture mainstream.
These mass-produced
rides would soon
become known as muscle cars.
DENNIS MCCARTHY:
Within General Motors,
everybody was trying to
then jump on that bandwagon,
because the car was
just a huge hit.
The car was everywhere.
It was like rock and roll.
You got to remember, all
these divisional managers
were competing
internally with Pontiac.
And that internal
competition is what created
that muscle car revolution.
NARRATOR: GM's individual
brands were off to the races
to make their own
muscle cars and cash in.
Buick had the Skylark.
Chevy debuted the
Chevelle SS and the Nova.
The success of these
new muscle cars
was undeniable, thanks to
the DeLorean and Wangers
sidestepping the rules.
They had revolutionized
the auto industry.
The muscle car had its
roots in these outlaw hot rods
and all this back channel
stuff, but now you
can go to your dealer,
and you could get the car.
They commercialized a rebellion.
NARRATOR: With an
idea so popular,
GM wouldn't be the only muscle
purveyor in town for long.
The auto industry is
great at imitating success.
And so once GM did it, then
everybody else said, oh, maybe
we need to do that as well.
JEFF THISTED: If they're doing
it, then it's safe for us.
We're not the guys
hanging out there alone.
At least they're doing
it first, and it's
all about making money.
So you put the big engine
into the little car,
it's a winning combination.
[tiger growl]